the bachelorette brought us the sexiest
episode yet until we were thrust down a
hole of darkness as we watched wills sob
it's time for roses and rose hey you
guys oh my god I'm wearing blue like the
ocean because the Bachelorette finally
gave me what I had been asking for color
sexuality the lamb yes guys did this
episode make you feel invested in the
show again let me know I was ill last
week but this week I'm feeling
revitalized replenished just like the
beach will do to someone and just like
it did to this show this week and I've
got a big old glass of my favorite brand
of Rose a let's get to it I have so much
to talk about so first of all ocean
shots of the ocean blue ocean colors
even Becca cannot deny she says quote
yes after last week's episode this is
exactly what we needed just when we're
hanging on by a thread of fandom this
show comes through but don't drink every
time Becca says she's never been here
before my first time becca also tells
chris that she's hoping for no drama no
drama
but becca again we need some drama
we need to stir some stuff up we need
some drama Oh Rama we need a pina colada
of drama in the Bahamas okay thank you
and luckily we got it
more to come so I'm also gonna call out
a little bit this episode you guys not
only did the shots and the visuals and
the dates look better but Becca looked
great her makeup looked gorgeous in the
Bahamas and I just think that's so
impressive because it was probably the
most difficult climate in which to work
with said hair and makeup so great so
things are gonna start right away and
Colton gets the one-on-one and Blake's
not happy about it Garrett's not
everybody's making a face everybody's
unhappy this is the way the game works
guys speaking of how I always not really
meaning to but forget Colton a little
bit I forgot that cool
still hasn't told Becca he's a virgin so
that's gonna be a big thing on this date
virginity version originated I am a
virgin virgin anything or ganodi the
guys are acting like it's this big deal
for him to tell Becca this Colton's very
nervous about how she'll react you guys
tell me what you would say if someone
you were on a date with and have been
dating told you that they were a virgin
would it be some kind of problem for you
I really want to know what you think I
also want to take a moment to commend
another visual wills and Garrett in
these shirt prints I mean wills
especially you guys he is a grown man
working an animal print collared shirt
and that will not be the last wills look
that we look at this episode I'm sorry
for all the puns I'm just in such a good
mood because it was such a good episode
so Becca says to Colton you give up
Cameron how do you feel about catamarans
and I just laughed right out loud at
that because what a weirdly specific
question have you ever asked anyone that
you guys let me know in the comments
what would your answer be how do you
feel about catamarans I just feel glad
that we're going on a boat with a
shirtless man cat or a man more puns
anyway so as we know Becca is very
physically attracted to cold she says he
could pick me up and do well lol because
we don't know if Colton knows what to do
another shout-out Becca is looking great
in this orange swimsuit it is actually
by a line called Becca swim I'm not
plugging the line I'm not paid to say
that I just thought that was funny so
they're getting snuggly and sexy and
doing that king of the world thing that
we got to do at least once a season in
this franchise
and a man arrives on a yellow boat just
as coldness seemingly about to tell
Becca the news version when then turns
out everything that's gonna be said is
pretty much penis jokes
you need the pistol the Bahamian viagra
the Bahamian viagra yes it's not about a
word to say it's just a it's a word it's
a reality you're giving a pleaser and
not teaser don't drink every time they
make a conch joke pun you guys
[Music]
I do pecans is much harder than I ever
could
[Music]
yes 8:8 conk nether region sex joke puns
wonderful isn't this nice this is insane
and then we go to dinner and at dinner
Colton does tell Becca that he's a
virgin really and he says this was a
little confusing to me he says only a
handful of people know you know I'm not
even sure to be honest with you like my
dad knows is so into help on this
episode is I was drinking he was a yet
I'm gonna catch up with myself you know
I'm not even sure to be honest with you
like my dad knows golden spells Becca
he's not even sure if his dad knows well
he knows now did you tell him before
this episode on national television I
really want to know I tweeted cool at
the NASA
I'll get the answer Jim for one second
Becca takes this news and they show her
getting up for a second leaving Colton
after his vulnerable reveal and here's
the thing guys wow that was great TV
Becca took to Twitter and said that she
was just going to the bathroom and
Colton sub tweeted her and said
confirmed there was no disrespect so the
power of editing made for a great
episode but also we've used Twitter to
debunk the fake news I want to meet the
people who mean Colton under life okay
Colton gets a rose he's going to
hometowns then we cut to Garrett and
Becca on a seaplane wonderful they're
gonna go island hopping I think we're
swinging around around the island Swing
great I do wonder if Becca was getting
touch-ups during this because at one
point she had her hair in a messy bun
and she was still looking so great I'm
also trying to find this answer out was
she fixing herself up it just seems so
humid I'm not perfect I know you're not
perfect the world's not perfect I think
that we can do
then Garrett does some imperfect math
about being perfect that makes no sense
Garrett the math isn't there if neither
of you is perfect why would you be
perfect
am I being cynical I don't I didn't get
the equation and it's adding up to a lot
of question marks for me
some of you noted that I have not been
talking that much about Garrett's
Instagram scandal well let me talk about
it right now he apologized for it I
thought his apology could have been
better I think that he needs to own what
he did on social media and that when you
like a post it is kind of an endorsement
of how you feel so I'm excited to hear
from Garrett more and I don't want to
place judgment on him now because I
haven't even met him yet and he's
certainly not been convicted of a crime
like Lincoln was so there is a
differentiation there for me but I did
think of the Instagram scandal tonight
because Becca asked Garrett are used on
Twitter came over on me and I had no
idea what this meant and I was like well
this would be funny if it's a Twitter
thing and he had this social media
scandal but no then someone told me it's
a reference to the movie Bambi hated
which was around far before any social
media nearly everybody gets twitterpated
in the springtime anyway so have you
guys forgiven Garrett for his Instagram
scandal let me know how you feel again I
just want to get to know a little bit
more about him at this point
Blake gets the one-on-one and Blake and
his palm tree shirt we're barely holding
on he said so good thing he got one
because it had been a minute for him
Blake and his palm tree shirt are
relieved Jason and his big cross he's
wearing are praying for more time with
Becca Leo and his tank top are sweating
over what's going on and Will's and his
red pants are on fire because they all
have to go with a three on one I told
you guys I'm gonna drink every time I'm
myself I'm going to over the top but
she's like so hot but hidden like
screaming and yelling and then Garrett
gets into his ex-wife and he really from
whatever they showed of this
conversation maybe more God edited out
but really kind of blamed her for their
divorce entirely saying the problem with
his ex was that she was a hothead
from the very beginning of the
relationship she would act out like that
but Garrett tells Becca that he's
falling in love with her and don't drink
every time Becca says that she likes
seeing different sides of someone
because that was her thing this episode
so everybody's falling in love we're at
that stage of the show and then we get
something sexy
Becca gives Garrett of rose and then
they frolic in the water ah I'm just
glad about that I'm just glad we got it
I'm getting glammed I'm getting good
different looks from both Becca and the
guys I'm getting drama I'm getting
emotional with feels I'm getting then we
are gonna get Blake's one-on-one and
while we got Colton's big admission this
episode perhaps the most important
reveal is that the group the Baha men is
still around and that they have a new
song great I didn't catch the name but I
want to commend Blake for his dancing
because he's a larger man and he was
really getting out there and moving it I
like a guy who dances I say even if
you're a bad dancer I'd rather you dance
poorly than not at all it's about effort
so Blake seems surprised that Becca has
feelings for other guys and Blake I know
it's been a minute for you and so you're
feeling a little insecure but that is
the show what's interesting who is that
Becca that just straight-up says that
she feels the most strongly about Blake
which took me aback because she again
just hasn't seen in so long I do wonder
if some of their moments have been
edited out cuz that felt a little bit
out of left field what do you guys think
we've got a surprise for you to hear
that Becca has the strongest feelings
for Blake and she only gets more into it
but first a family over shared don't
drink every time you get a family or
share this episode we need gold rabirius
dad doesn't know he's a virgin
Garrett revealing that his ex-wife is
sometime hothead and now Blake is
revealing but his parents divorced when
he was in high school because his mom
had an affair with his coach Wow god I
hope these families got heads-up before
all this this is right oh but I'm gonna
drink for Blake's mom that's a lot and
so if I've learned anything is that I
want
openness and I like that I liked it
instead of I think when we're faced with
adversity we can often become just like
the problem or we can decide to be
different and Blake decided to be
different he wants to have a very open
family and I think that's great
then Blake tells Becca he is in love
with her and at first I was like whoa
Blake this is a lot everybody else is
just at the falling in love stage but
then drink every time my mind was blown
Becca says you make my heart Brooks says
that she wants to hear me say it over
and over again my heart just recognizes
his and then says she defects in way she
is in love with him she just can't tell
him it's so difficult to hold back I was
blown away guys I did not see that
coming did you that guy's in love with
Blake that changes the way I'm looking
at everything
oh this show makes it interesting to
think about how things will end up
doesn't it because I have kind of insane
Blake for bachelor we'll get to that
well here we go so now we have the three
on one and Will's is willing that he
will get a rose by wearing a tank top
covered in flowers this man's fashion
choices are just so impressive and I'm
the three-on-one they're playing beach
volleyball I mean after the catamaran
and the seaplane this seems pretty low
effort on the part of production and it
feels strange doesn't it because we now
know she's in love with Blake and then
she's playing beach volleyball with
these three dudes so it feels a little
low stakes to close the episode out with
now singing milk last three days that's
not easy right Jason I love Jason more
and more every week you guys he says to
her of his feelings that the process at
this point quote you know what it's not
easy but it's not supposed to be easy
right so Jason yes you are on a TV show
thank you for realizing that Blake is
having a problem with realizing that and
then Becca and Leo take a moment and you
guys Leo's hair in this moment it's been
standout all season long but to me
things went to another level here I mean
that hair had a mind of its own once it
got to the B
to the ocean breeze blowing backwards
leo looks like a romance novel cover and
to just really highlight it I'm gonna
bring in our favorite romance cover
model on the journey with JC this week
is just about him recreating Leo's hair
blown luck
[Music]
I love it hated so Becca breaks things
off with Leo despite how great his hair
looks we knew this was coming right and
she's just so much further with the
other guys Leo's still great and gosh
his body looked great too i mean just
props to Leo I think he's wonderful and
that made it even more sad when they
boat it away past him and he was just
walking on the beach alone his hair was
still kind of blowing it felt like he'd
been left behind
you know when they leave someone behind
on a two-on-one because they're a
villain or something and he wasn't so Oh
leo
we then go to the dinner portion of the
date and Jason and Will's are both there
and first wills gets kind of emotional
talking about Becca - Becca and then
Becca basically explained do I go with
somebody that I feel strongly for who's
already all-in or do I go with somebody
who I also feel strongly for but I don't
know if he's quite there with me and who
will she sent home wills oh you guys
this was heart-wrenching
I mean wills is crying and Becca is like
whispering to him see and I couldn't
believe Becca wasn't crying how is she
not crying
I was crying then wills gets in the car
and he's crying more he has to stop the
car because he's crying so much and that
brings us to our last question of the
night will wills be the bachelor so
after this happened wills for bachelor
was trending on Twitter you guys and I
have to say if you've been with me for a
while you know that for example on
Rachel Lindzi season I was very hardcore
Peter crossed for bachelor nobody else
was really on my mind of course we all
know how that ended up
we didn't get him but this season I'm a
little more torn I really like Blake but
Willis has really grown on me and I must
say I like Jason a lot too he's real
funny so wills emotional exit might
bring him up a notch in terms of Reese
for bachelor and wouldn't it be
wonderful to have our first black
bachelor
what do you guys think who is a bachelor
frontrunner at this point for you thank
you so much everyone for being here as
we watched our blues for last week away
with the bright blues of the Bahamian
ocean hand with the conch Lauren went
out for the conch everybody
I loved this episode of Becca kufran
season of The Bachelorette and as always
want your thoughts please leave them in
the comments below
message me anytime and here we go we've
got a hometowns next week can't wait
[Music]